prince william
might be a busy royal but he made sure
he spent father's day with his kids
the data three brought his two eldest
children to work seven-year-old prince
george and six-year-old princess
charlotte
the royals visited the sandringham
estate in norfolk england to kick off a
local half marathon
and we love a fam who color coordinates
george and charlotte matched their dad
in navy shorts
with a young prince wearing a plaid
button-down shirt while his sister
sported a pastel pink polo sweater
can you name a better trio we'll wait
in addition to father's day the duke of
cambridge who is also dad to
three-year-old son louis
celebrated his 39th birthday on monday
yeah all very excited
and he's getting lots of love from his
royal family his father prince charles
marked the occasion with a sweet
throwback photo of himself holding
william as a baby
he captioned it wishing the duke of
cambridge a very happy birthday today
the royal family account which
represents queen elizabeth
also shared a sweet family photo of
william with wife kate middleton
and their three children writing wishing
the duke of cambridge a very happy
birthday today
the duke also showed his appreciation as
he thanked friends family and followers
for the well wishes on his special day
prince william's back-to-back
celebrations come after his
sister-in-law meghan markle shared the
touching gift she gave william's brother
prince harry
on his first father's day last year as
most of us do you go what am i going to
get them as a gift
and i and i thought i just wanted
something sentimental and a place for
him
to have as a bit of a home base with our
son
in her first interview following their
bombshell sit down with oprah winfrey
the duchess of sussex opened up to npr
weekend edition on sunday about her new
children's book
the bench which inspired the bench he
gifted harry just weeks after their now
two-year-old son archie was born
you know i often find especially in this
past year i think so many of us
realize how much happens in the quiet
in the story i'm observing this love
between my husband
and our son and imagining what it will
be
as they have more shared moments as our
son gets older so from
scraping a knee to having a heart broken
whatever it is that they always reset at
this bench and have this moment to bond
on the back of harry's bench megan wrote
a poem that reads
this is your bench where life will begin
for you and our son
our baby our kin
[Music]
megan and harry are now the parents of
two after welcoming their daughter
lillabet diana
earlier this year et recently caught up
with royal expert katie nickel
who says there is hope that megan and
harry's new daughter will help
mend the current rift between the couple
and the royal family
this family division has really gone on
for
a very long time now it's well over a
year it's been
many many months since charles the queen
indeed the cambridges have seen archie
in the flesh and we know that there have
been some
really quite deep problems between harry
and william
difficulties between harry and his
father and i think it's everyone's
hope that this little baby will will be
a peace offering
in many ways and that she will help to
bring this divided family
back together